>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Hello.
Hello. Can everybody hear me?
Awesome. Welcome, guys.
Welcome to the Library
of Congress.
Who's been here before?
Oh. Very good.
And everybody here
has now been here.
So that's really exciting.
So welcome to the
Library of Congress,
and welcome to the
Young Readers Center.
And what school are
you guys with today?
Yeah. Shout it out.
Shout it out.
>> Ludlow-Taylor.
>> Sasha Dowdy: That's awesome.
Welcome Ludlow-Taylor.
It's so good to have you.
So today we have a very special
program with you, for you guys.
But first I have a question.
So we're talking
about a woman today.
Do you guys know who it is?
She lives in New York,
and she holds a torch,
and she is walking forward.
Who is it?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. It's the Statue of Liberty.
You guys are on point, and
maybe you saw something
to give you a clue behind me.
So yes. We're talking about
the Statue of Liberty,
and specifically a book
called "Her Right Foot"
about the Statue of Liberty.
And we have the illustrator,
the artist Shawn Harris,
who created this book with
Dave Eggers here today with us
which is really exciting.
And we're talking about --
So Shawn Harris is the
illustrator who's here today.
And he came here all the way
from Morongo Valley, California.
And he's a musician and he's an
artist and he's worked with tons
of people that you
may actually know.
He has his own band,
the Matches.
He's also done work with Adele.
You guys know Adele?
Yeah. Pretty big deal.
Snoop Dogg.
Yeah? Maybe you've heard
of a band called 311.
Yeah? Okay.
So he's done work with
all these amazing people,
and so he has this
really cool music career,
but now he has published a
book with author Dave Eggers.
So he's going to talk
to you about that.
You guys excited?
So before he comes out
and starts the program,
I just want to say thank you
to An Open Book Foundation,
and this is an organization
that's local to DC
that really cares
about kids reading.
And what do they do to make
sure that kids are reading?
Well, they buy books.
So all of you guys are
walking away with a book,
"Her Right Foot," at the
end of the program today.
So how about we give
them a round of applause?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's going to be a good time.
So how about we get started?
Welcome, Shawn Harris.
[ Applause ]
>> Shawn Harris:
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Please. Please.
Please. Well, you guys already
guessed who this book is about.
"Her Right Foot" is about
the Statue of Liberty.
So I guess we're done.
That's -- No.
This book is full of all
kinds of interesting things
that I learned while I
was illustrating the book
about the statue.
The book does some
kind of cool stuff.
I'm going to let you
decide for yourself.
Can I read you this book?
Is that cool with you guys?
Okay. All right.
All right.
And for everybody
that has been cutting
out paper diligently while
you're waiting for me
to get introduced, thank you.
I will collect that
in a little bit.
Just hold on to your shapes
right now, and we're going
to do an art project together.
But you guys might notice
when I start reading the book
that I made this whole book
with little cut out pieces
of paper exactly the same
as what you just did.
Yeah. Yeah.
So if you photographed that,
that could be in a book one day.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, and you can go
past this video.
Okay. All right.
Let's sync this up.
Okay. Here are my end papers.
These are called end
papers right here.
I'm just testing
you here, Sasha.
These are called end papers.
I'm going to take the
jacket off of the book.
This is called a jacket.
It's a very kind of formal
thing that protects the book.
Underneath the jacket you guys
might recognize this tablet.
This tablet, there's
a date on it.
It says July 4, 1886.
It's interesting.
Does that date sound familiar?
Yeah. Yeah.
1776. You're right [laughs].
So this is when the "Declaration
of Independence" was signed.
And this is the tablet
that the statue is holding.
So you can hold this book
and pose like the statue.
Anyway, okay.
Here we go.
"Her Right Foot."
Said it twice just in case
you missed it that first time.
Okay. You have likely heard
of a place called France.
Is that true?
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Good.
Starting off on the right foot.
Okay. If you have
heard of France,
you may have heard
of the French.
They are the people
who live in France.
Do we need to move this
while we're doing the --
Is that better?
Okay. Cool.
We'll put that up in a minute.
All right.
So you have heard of the French.
Where do they live?
France. That's right.
Okay. Cool.
Cool. We're up to speed.
Everyone's on the right page.
You may have also heard
of something called
the Statue of Liberty.
Right? Right?
Did you know that the Statue
of Liberty comes from France?
This is true.
This is a factual book.
One day a Frenchman named
Edouard de Laboulaye had
an idea.
The idea was to celebrate the
hundred years the United States
of America had been around by
giving them a giant sculpture.
So he convinced another
Frenchman,
a Frenchman with an Italian last
name, to design the sculpture.
This artist's name was
Frederic Auguste Bartholdi.
Bartholdi designed the statue.
Now you might see that our
Frenchman here is holding a
banana up in the air.
Does anybody have any idea why?
Is he just -- You have an idea?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. It's like the torch.
Right? They don't serve
torches with breakfast.
So you have an idea too?
[ Inaudible ]
Also true.
You use what you have, and
if you only have a banana,
but you have an idea and
it involves holding a torch
up high, you're going to hold
that banana up in the air.
And in his other hand you
see he's got something.
He's holding sort
of like a tablet.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So the Statue of
Liberty is not holding a menu.
What's that?
You can't see the pictures?
Do you need me to stand?
I can stand back here.
Is that better?
Okay. All right.
Great. You still see?
Okay. Good.
Good. Okay.
Okay. So he first made
the statue very small,
very small models
of the sculpture.
Then larger ones.
And finally the one that we know
which stands 305
feet above the water.
It's tall.
Yeah. This final full
sized version was covered
with a thin copper skin.
The skin is about as
thick as two pennies.
Anybody have two pennies?
It's not very thick.
Right? You'd think she would
get cold standing out there
in the winter in New York.
Right? Yeah.
You have two.
He has two coins right here.
You guys can see.
This is not pennies, but
it's close to the width.
This is the thickness
of her skin.
You can barely see that.
Right? That does not
translate on camera here.
What's that?
Well, we'll find out why she
doesn't fall down in a minute
because they're building
the statue right now.
So here is Bartholdi
and his team.
He had a team.
He didn't like working alone.
And they're constructing
the statue's hand.
Notice that this hand is
bigger than these men.
Thus they made the
statue in many parts.
You can see this hand is taking
up the entire warehouse
right here.
You can see that.
That's the actual size
of the men on the hand.
Yes. You have an idea,
a question, a theory?
What's that?
How did they make it bigger?
Like how did they attach
it to the whole statue?
We'll find out.
These parts were assembled,
and that's when they put it
all together, in New York City.
No. No. No.
Wait. Wait.
Wait. First they were
assembled in Paris.
Did you know this?
Ask your friends, and
even your teachers,
if they knew before the Statue
of Liberty was assembled
in New York, she was first
constructed in Paris.
Your friends and teachers
will be astounded.
They will be impressed.
Are you impressed,
teachers and friends?
Yeah. They might think
that you are fibbing,
but you are not fibbing.
This really happened.
The Statue of Liberty stood
there high above Paris
for almost a year in 1884.
After they assembled the statue
in Paris, they took it apart.
Okay? "But we just put it
together," the workers said.
"That is absurd," they said.
They said all this in French,
the language of the French.
A people who appreciate
the absurd.
[ Inaudible ]
Why did they take
it down in Paris?
Because they were
bringing it to America.
It was a gift from
the French, actually.
In 1885, after they took it
apart, they put the parts
in 214 crates, put
these crates on a boat.
The boat was called the Isere.
The boat traveled over the
Atlantic Ocean, and made its way
to a city called New York
also in a state called --
>> New York.
>> Shawn Harris: New York.
In the United States.
Correct. And here they are
traveling across the Atlantic.
Yes.
>> Then how did it
get to -- How --
Then how did it get to
New York [inaudible].
>> No. It was a gift
from the French.
>> Shawn Harris: It was
a gift from the French
to the United States to help
us celebrate our independence,
the 100 year anniversary
of our independence.
So it's coming up.
We're not at 1886 yet.
We're in about 1884, 1885.
Okay. Hundreds of workers,
perhaps 214 of them,
took the pieces out
of the 214 boxes,
then began to rivet
the pieces together.
Assembling the statue took 17
months, and it all happened
on what was then called
Bedloe's Island right here.
Does anybody know what
the island is called now?
>> Liberty Island.
>> Shawn Harris: Liberty Island.
Really good.
Good work.
Yeah. The statue was so big
and prominent they named the --
They renamed the
island after the statue.
Bartholdi liked to see the
sculpture rise above the harbor.
Sometimes he'd watch the
construction from the water.
Sometimes he watched
it from the land.
Usually he was wearing a
sturdy black hat for he,
like most European men of
the time, and some artists,
favored sturdy black hats.
You may have noticed by now
that the pictures of the Statue
of Liberty in this book
have her colored brown.
You may have thought that the
illustrator of this book was not
so good at his job because
we all know the Statue
of Liberty is a certain
greenish-blue color.
Right? But the Statue of
Liberty was made of copper,
that stuff that pennies are
made out of, and copper starts
out the color of pennies.
Brown. Then very slowly
when it's left outside
for long periods of time,
copper will eventually oxidize.
And when it does, it turns --
>> Green.
>> Shawn Harris: Yeah.
First red, brown, greenish.
Green. And then that kind
of light teal that --
And that's the color that
we know she is today.
Right? Crazy.
So if you left your pennies
out in the New York harbor
for 100 years you would have the
Statue of Liberty colored penny
if they were still
made of copper.
Okay. So the Statue of
Liberty that everyone
in New York City saw being
constructed was actually brown.
The Statue of Liberty, in fact,
was brown for about 35 years.
Yeah. But see.
We don't know.
When we look at old pictures
of the Statue of Liberty,
the photography was
all black and white.
So in our minds we're
like, "Oh, yeah.
That's a big teal statue."
The statue turned
green around 1920,
and it has been this
color ever since.
And perhaps you already
knew this.
And you may have known that the
book the statue is carrying,
the one in her left hand,
features the date, July 4, 1776,
on which the "Declaration
of Independence" was signed.
Right? Roman numerals.
And you may know
that the seven spikes
on her crown represent
the seven seas on Earth,
and the seven continents,
and the sun rays too.
And you probably know that the
torch she carries is a symbol
of enlightenment, lighting the
path to liberty and to freedom.
And you might have known that
at one point Thomas Edison,
the inventor of the light
bulb and the record player,
once proposed to have a giant
record player inside the Statue
of Liberty.
Yeah. He did.
He wanted the statue
to be able to speak.
In the end, though, this idea
was considered a little bit
strange, and was not pursued.
They didn't do it.
They -- We kept the light bulb,
but we didn't use
the giant phonograph.
I mean can you imagine
how hard it would be
to like clean the dust
off of a giant phonograph?
You know? Yeah.
And would she be singing?
Would she be like singing
an Adele song up there
in the harbor or something?
>> They would also
have to clean --
They would also have to
have big giant records.
>> Shawn Harris: Yes.
They would.
And then who gets to
choose the record?
It's always, you know --
Oh, is it your turn
to choose the record?
And everybody [inaudible]
anyway.
The idea was not pursued.
Did you know that the interior
of the statue was designed
by another Frenchman
by the name of Eiffel ?
Does that sound familiar?
Eiffel Tower?
That's right.
The same Eiffel who a few
years later would design the
Eiffel Tower.
I think it was about six years
after he designed the Statue
of Liberty he did
the Eiffel Tower.
So yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And did you know
that while the statue was first
being constructed in Paris,
a bunch of Parisians, mostly
writers who liked to eat,
actually dined in the area just
below the statue's knee before
they even put her torso on?
This too is true.
While the statue was
rising, Bartholdi set
up a lunch four stories
up to impress
and enthrall these French
writers who, being difficult
to impress and enthrall,
were at least mildly amused.
Did you say, "How much
did the lunch cost?"
>> I said how much is four --
>> Shawn Harris: Oh.
How much is four stories?
Well, we're on the
second story right now.
Is that right?
We're on the ground.
Okay. Okay.
But we did climb
some stairs to get --
[ Inaudible ]
So your library at school
is on the third floor.
So one more floor up and
you're at the statue's knee.
Yeah. Yeah.
Are you at least mildly amused?
But there is one thing
that you might not know,
and this is the central
point to this book,
a point that the author,
my friend Dave Eggers,
apologizes for taking
so long to get to.
The point is that even if
you have seen a picture
of the Statue of Liberty or
many pictures of the Statue
of Liberty, or even hundreds
of pictures of the Statue
of Liberty, you have probably
not seen pictures of her feet.
Have you? Okay.
Let's check this out.
And even if you have seen
pictures of her feet,
like this one, you probably
have not seen pictures
of the back of her feet.
In particular, her right foot.
What do you notice when
you see this picture?
Her foot is up.
What is that?
What could that mean?
We notice like this
her foot is up.
What could that mean?
>> She's moving.
>> Shawn Harris:
That she's moving.
Yeah. She's about
to go somewhere.
Let's talk about that.
That's right.
She is going somewhere.
She is on the move.
Let's pause here and
collect ourselves.
Let's think about this.
Let's pause here and
think about this.
Let's discuss this.
Let's think about
and discuss the fact
that this is the largest
sculpture in all of our land.
And the most iconic symbol of
the United States of America.
Let's talk about the fact that
the statue has welcomed millions
of visitors and immigrants to
the United States of America.
People talk about
her unusual headwear.
They talk about her gown
which seems a very heavy kind
of garment which
would likely result
in serious lower back issues.
Right? They talk about
her beautiful torch,
and the severe look on her face.
But no one talks about the
fact that she's walking.
This 150 foot woman is
on the go, like you said.
Every time we see the Statue
of Liberty in pictures
or any time we imagine
the Statue
of Liberty we see
her standing still,
very still, like,
well, a statue.
But she's moving.
She weighs 450,000 pounds,
and wears a size 879 shoe.
What size shoe do you wear?
No 879, huh?
No. How can we all
have missed this?
Or even if we saw
this, and noticed this,
how is it that we have seen and
noticed a 450,000 pound human
on her way somewhere
and said, "Oh,
just another 150 foot woman
walking off 150 foot pedestal.
No big deal."
Most important, where
is she going?
Is she going to SoHo
to get a panini?
Have you ever had a panini?
Neither have I.
Is she going to West Village to
look for vintage Nico records?
No. No. No.
She's facing southwest.
So she's facing New Jersey.
Could she be going to Trenton?
Wait. No. No.
No. She's facing southeast.
So she's not going
to New Jersey.
But she is going somewhere.
Where is she going?
There are certain
things that we know.
We know that around
her feet are chains.
They are broken chains, implying
that she's freed
herself from bondage.
We know that Bartholdi
wanted us to know this.
He wanted us to see the chains.
People have talked
about the chains.
But few talk about the foot that
is so obviously in midstride,
about the fact that her entire
right leg is in midstride.
What does this mean?
What does this mean
that we often forget
about the right foot,
the right leg?
Here's an idea.
Here's a theory.
Here's a reminder.
If the Statue of Liberty is a
symbol of freedom, if the Statue
of Liberty has welcomed
millions of immigrants
to the United States, then
how can she stand still?
Liberty and freedom from
oppression are not things
that you get or grant
by standing
around like some kind of statue.
No. These are things that
require action and courage
and an unwillingness to rest.
The Statue of Liberty
was not built
to welcome just 1,886 immigrants
from Italy one certain
Sunday in, say, 1886.
No. She was built to
welcome 3,000 immigrants
from Poland the next day, the
next day 5,000 Norwegians,
after that 10,000 Glaswegians,
then Cambodians, then Estonians,
Somalis, Nepalis,
Syrians, Liberians.
It never ends.
It cannot end.
After all, the Statue of
Liberty is an immigrant too.
And this is why she's moving.
This is why she's striding.
In welcoming the poor,
the tired, the struggling,
to breathe free, she
is not content to wait.
She must meet them in the sea.
And that's the end.
[ Applause ]
And because this is
a very special event,
I'm really honored to be here
at the Library of Congress.
I actually brought the
original piece that I did
with construction paper of
this last page of the book.
Can you guys see this?
This is the first
time that I did this,
and then they printed
this in the book.
And it's the last page.
Do you guys have any questions
about the book, the
words or the art?
Yes. What's your question back
here in the glitter cat shirt.
>> I have to think about it.
>> Shawn Harris: You
have to think about it?
Okay. I'll come back to you.
Do you want to look at that?
This is the original of this.
How did I make it out of paper?
Well, all I did was I
just cut out the shapes
and then I glued
them on the page.
Yeah. You can see it.
Right? Yeah.
Yeah. You have a question
right here in the cat ears.
>> How do you keep
-- How do you --
How did you make the
Statue of Liberty?
>> Shawn Harris: Well, I did
not make the Statue of Liberty,
but the Statue of Liberty
that is right here in my piece
of art I just -- You know what?
I cut out a shape,
and before I drew
on it it didn't really look very
much like the Statue of Liberty.
It's kind of sort of
a rectangle with an --
maybe an arm-like shape
protruding in to the air.
And then I -- See how
I painted the yellow
and teal paint on
top of that shape?
And all of a sudden it looked
like the Statue of Liberty.
That's pretty crazy.
You should try it.
You have a question right
here in the front row?
Yes?
>> How did you make
it so realistic?
>> Shawn Harris: You
think this is realistic?
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Practice. Practice, I guess.
But you'll see.
We're going to do an
art project together
when I pick this
up off the ground.
We're going to do an art
project together, and you'll get
to see my work in action, how
I glue everything on the page.
And you know what?
It's not different.
It's not much different
from the way you do things
at home probably,
which is kind of cool.
You have a question
right here in the yellow.
I know. The mouth gets dry when
you talk in front of people.
Right?
>> How come on the
-- on that one most
of the lines are thicker
than the ones on that one?
>> Shawn Harris: That's
an interesting question.
She says how come the lines
are thicker than on this one?
And the answer is I did the ink
on a different layer
on this one.
So this is the actual paper
that's photographed here,
but I did the ink on a separate
piece of paper and then scanned
that in for the book
in case I messed up.
And then after I decided I liked
it, I went and did my final.
You have a question.
>> What -- Did you use -- What
kind of paint did you use?
Like watercolor?
>> Shawn Harris: I used mostly
ink, and I used some acrylic.
And a little bit of watercolor.
Yeah. So pretty much
anything that was laying
around that was the right color.
Let's see.
Another question.
You have a question.
>> Why did you choose
to do this book?
>> Shawn Harris: Why did
I choose to do this book?
That's a really good question.
I got to read the
book, and they asked me
if I would do some samples
in cut paper because they --
Dave, the author, wanted
this book done in cut paper.
And so I said, "Oh, yeah.
No problem.
I can do my art with cut paper."
And then I ran home and did some
art to make sure that I could
because I just told them, "Yes.
I can do that."
And I didn't know that I could.
And I showed it to
him, and he liked it.
But the reason why I did the
book was I read the manuscript
which is just the words
without the pictures.
And I was really inspired.
I thought it was
a great message.
I was feeling a little
bit like I didn't --
I was a bit frustrated, didn't
have a way of communicating
that I thought everybody
should be welcomed
in to the United States, and
this book really says that.
I think my favorite
line from this book is
when it says the Statue of
Liberty is an immigrant too.
And I thought about, you know,
my great grandparents
that immigrated here.
They came over on boats to
seek a better life in America.
And how I'm just so lucky
to have been born here.
You know? But people are
arriving here every day
that are looking for -- that
want their kids to be born here
like we were or like a lot
of us were, I should say.
Unless you're Native American,
your family immigrated here.
And the story of
immigrating to America is
such an American story, right?
Like that's who we all are.
And so it's really important
that we celebrate people
that have immigrated here and
are immigrating here every day.
They are really brave,
heroic American people.
So yes. You have a question?
>> So basically the
statue is an immigrant,
and even though [inaudible]
immigrant too.
>> Shawn Harris: Yeah.
She's standing in the harbor
there in New York City
where the most people
immigrate to the United States,
and welcoming them
with her torch.
You have a question?
>> Yeah. My question
is how many years
or months did it
take you to do that?
>> Shawn Harris: How many years?
It -- You know, it took me --
I basically didn't sleep
for about six months.
Yeah. Yeah.
So maybe that's --
Should I call that a year
or should I call it six months?
Do we? Okay.
Okay. We'll just call
it six months then.
Yeah. That's hard?
Well, you -- How --
I slept a little bit.
You know, like when you
have a big project due?
And like the whole last night
you stay up and you work
on the project, and the next day
at school you're
like falling asleep?
That's how I was
for like six months.
Yeah. Because this book wasn't
originally going to come
out until next year, and
the publisher decided,
"We want to put this out now."
As soon as possible.
So they called me up and said,
"How fast can you
cut that paper?"
And I said, "Not much faster."
And they said, "Well, try."
And so I called -- I
actually called my mom.
And my mom lives in Arizona.
And I said, "Mom."
My mom taught me how to
cut paper when I was a kid.
And I said, "Mom,
can you come over
and help me cut some stuff out?"
And she did.
She drove to my house from
Arizona, and she helped me cut
out the paper that I
used for this book.
Yes. You have a question.
>> Does the author choose the
pictures that he wants you
to draw or do you choose them?
>> Shawn Harris:
We wok together.
I work together with the author.
But most of this book, most of
this book, I chose the pictures.
I sent them to the author.
And then he would maybe
have a little idea.
Like, for instance, on this page
this bird was pink, and he said,
"Hey, that pink bird,
I feel like maybe you're
gilding the lilies there."
And so I looked up that
phrase, and I went, "Okay.
I think if I just -- I'm
going to turn the bird brown."
And he said, "Perfect.
I love it."
So that's an example of
how we worked together.
Let's do one more question,
and then let's do an
art project together.
You have a question.
Yes.
>> How did you -- How did
you know if you had it right?
How did you --
>> Shawn Harris: How
did I know if I had --
if I was like drawing
the right thing?
Is that what you're
talking about?
>> And write it.
>> Shawn Harris: Well, like I
said, my friend wrote the book,
but both of us made --
Both of us had to do a lot
of research for the book.
Remember when I told you that
all the original pictures
of the Statue of Liberty
were in black and white.
So I was -- I had to
figure out, "Oh, okay.
So was she the color of a penny
here or was she green here?"
And then I sent in my
drawings to the publisher
that printed the book, and then
they have a whole team whose job
it is to fact check the book.
And so they actually came
back to me and they said, "Oh,
you know, in that picture
where she's holding the banana
in the air, well, your
coffee pot wasn't invented
for another 20 years.
You're going to have to put a
different coffee pot in there."
And so when you make
a factual book,
you have to get those
things right.
And luckily I was
working with a good team,
but with Dave there were a
couple things that he had
to change in the text as well.
We got a couple dates
wrong at certain times,
and we had to figure
out, okay, this is this.
But yeah. It was
a group project.
There were people working on
it, and they were looking things
up in books and going to places
like the Library of Congress
and making sure we were right.
So yeah. You have -- I'll let
you continue your question.
>> How did you know if
you had to put a date?
How did you know?
>> Shawn Harris: Well, those
same people would fact check.
So we would say a date,
and they would go,
"You just said the wrong date.
That was 100 years too late."
And we'd go, "Oh.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That's what I meant."
Okay. Should we do
some art together?
When we're done, if you
guys have questions for me
that you want to come ask
me, I'll be here hanging out.
So you can come.
If anybody at the end
wants to come and look
at the original art that
I put down somewhere,
and wants to come see
that closer or wants
to come ask me anything,
I'll be here.
Now you guys have shapes.
Can I get your shapes?
Yes. Awesome.
Okay. Brilliant.
Brilliant.
You know what?
I'm actually going to need --
I'm actually going
to need five helpers.
Can I get five helpers?
Okay. Like cat ears
and white shirt.
And yellow shirt and let's see.
Oh, I like your bow.
Come on forward right here.
And then one more helper.
You back there in
the green shirt.
Okay. All right.
If you guys would help me
collect the paper, and then stay
up here with me,
that would be great.
Maybe I can give you this
little stack right here.
Hi. Would you grab this
stack of paper right -- Oh.
Those are cool.
These are great.
Can you hold these?
Oh. Well, can you ask me
after we're done here?
Okay. So yeah.
Each of you, I want you each
to grab a little
pile of shapes here.
Okay? Okay.
Yeah. Why don't you
grab some of them?
Why don't you give
her some of them?
Are there any more
shapes out there?
Do you have some shapes?
I want each of you
to hold some shapes.
Okay? Okay.
So can -- That's okay.
You only need four.
Actually. What's your name?
Evelyn. And you are?
McKenzie [assumed spelling].
I like your name.
Your name is?
Landon. Okay.
McKenzie. Got it.
What's your name?
[Inaudible] good to meet you.
And your name is?
Amir [assumed spelling]
good to meet you.
I'm Shawn.
Okay. Can you give
some shapes to Evelyn?
Can you give Evelyn maybe
four of your shapes?
All right.
You guys each have some shapes.
Okay. If you guys
would stand up here
in a line right here,
stand in a line.
Stand in a line in
front of everybody here.
In front of everybody.
Okay. Okay.
All right.
So we're going to do
some art together.
You guys together right now
might have a microphone already.
Okay. I would like
each of you -- Okay.
No. The first one of you.
We're going to go in a row here.
You're standing next to me.
What's your name?
>> Dikaya [assumed spelling].
>> Shawn Harris: Dikaya.
You guys know Dikaya.
Okay. Dikaya, if you could
look through your shapes
and give me your
favorite shape cut out in
that pile right there.
Give me your favorite shape.
We're going to start
with Dikaya's shape here
that one of you guys cut out.
And we're going to --
That's a good shape.
Okay. All right.
Okay. What could -- What could
we interpret this shape to be?
You guys can -- You guys
can just shout it out.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. Let's go back
to the hands.
Let's go back to the hands.
I thought that was
going to be -- Okay.
You have an idea.
>> A leaf because
it has the stem.
>> Shawn Harris: A leaf.
Okay. Because it has a stem.
Now what if I turn
the shape this way?
What could it be now?
What could we interpret
this to mean?
Any ideas, theories, reminders?
An eye? That's cool.
That's cool.
What if I turn it that way?
Back to a leaf?
Let's go with the eye.
I think the eye is a cool idea.
I think the eye.
[ Inaudible ]
She says -- Wait.
Wait. Wait.
She says, "I made it.
It's supposed to be a leaf."
>> It could also be [inaudible].
>> Shawn Harris: It could.
It could be a lot of things,
but here's the cool
thing about making art.
And here's the cool thing
about looking at art.
Hold on, you guys.
You guys. This is actually my
favorite thing about the book
that I just read to
you is that the Statue
of Liberty is a piece of art.
You guys realize this giant
sculpture, that's art.
An artist made it.
Right? And this whole book is
the author Dave Eggers looking
at this piece of art and
saying, "What could this mean?"
And that is so interesting
to me because she says,
"This is a leaf because I
cut it out and it's a leaf."
Well, we can also
interpret it to be an eye.
So let's use it.
Can we use it as an eye?
Is that okay with you?
Okay. She says okay.
That's very big of you
to let us repurpose
and reinterpret your art.
So I have a glue
stick right here.
You guys have a glue stick
at your classroom at home?
Anything? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
This is art of the people.
Okay? You can all
do this at home.
You don't need any
fancy equipment.
Well, I might use the stem.
Watch this.
Okay. Still kind of --
Still kind of looks like
maybe it's a leaf sitting
on the ground, but
what if I go like.
What if I go like that?
Suddenly it doesn't look
like a leaf anymore.
Right? Okay.
Now thank you, Dikaya,
for that shape.
Landon, right?
Is it Landon?
Landon, what shape are we going
to use that you have selected?
>> We could use this heart.
>> Shawn Harris: Okay.
So Landon says -- Landon
says we can use this heart.
But what besides a heart
could we turn this in to?
Any ideas?
Yes. You in the yellow shirt.
>> The fire for the torch.
>> Shawn Harris:
Fire for a torch.
That would be a really
good fire.
What about if we
turn it that way?
Any ideas there?
You have an idea.
>> It could be a butt.
>> Shawn Harris: It.
Everybody has one.
It could be a butt.
What if -- What if
we turn it this way?
What do you think?
>> It can be lips.
>> Shawn Harris:
It could be lips?
Definitely.
Oh. That would be cool.
Let's do that.
This could be really
interesting.
All right.
We are going to turn
this in to big lips.
Cool. Cool.
Cool. Let's do it.
So I'm going to put a little bit
of glue on our page right here.
You want to take it off?
You can take it off.
You don't want it?
Yeah. Come help me.
You can just pull it off.
Go for it.
There you go.
Okay. All right.
And remind me your name.
McKenzie. McKenzie just said
you should take that little,
the hair on the bottom
of her lip, off.
And so I let her do that.
That was her decision.
Okay. McKenzie, you
have a shape for us?
Oh. McKenzie, that's cool.
That's a cool shape.
You got some crazy
scissors, huh?
What could we interpret
McKenzie's shape as?
What could that be, everybody?
What could that be?
You have an idea?
>> A person.
>> Shawn Harris: It
could be a person.
What do you see?
What part of a person
do you see?
You see some arms and legs?
Okay. What if I turn
it this way?
What could that be?
Could be a bunny for sure.
For sure. Wait.
You have an idea.
>> Crab.
>> Shawn Harris: It
could be a crab for sure.
For sure. You have an
idea in the yellow shirt.
>> It could be a dress.
>> Shawn Harris: It
could be a dress?
That would be cool.
That would be -- I
feel like there's sort
of a story taking shape here.
It could be hair.
Oh. He said it could be hair.
I think this could be really --
This could be really
good hair, I think.
Let's see.
What if we just kind
of put it right there?
Does that look like
hair to you guys?
>> No.
>> Shawn Harris: What if
we -- It could be a bow.
That would be a good -- Yeah.
Let's make it a bow.
That's a good idea.
Okay. So first before we do --
Before we put the bow on our
character's head right here,
I'm going to give it some hair.
Okay? Okay?
That way. Otherwise what do
you tie the bow to, right?
Okay. All right.
All right.
Oh. That's cool.
Okay. Which way do we want
to put our bow right here?
Like that?
Yeah. That's cool.
Oh. That's really nice.
That's really nice.
That's nice.
I like that.
Okay. We have a couple more.
We have a couple more people.
Oh. That's cool.
That's cool.
Wait. Hold on.
Wait. And your name was?
Evelyn. Okay.
You guys. Thank you.
So Evelyn just picked
out a shape.
We're going to use
this shape next.
We have a lot of red
shapes which I like.
We're going kind
of monochromatic
which really makes
the eyes stand out.
Right? When we're using
all red and black,
and then we've just got
this one different color,
it really makes me
focus on that.
I like that.
I think this is cool.
What can we use this shape as?
Yes. Yellow shirt.
>> We could use it as
something like a car.
>> Shawn Harris:
Something like a car.
Oh. She could be parking a car.
She would be getting in a car.
She'd be like calling a car.
You have an idea?
Yeah.
>> A neck.
>> Shawn Harris: A neck.
This could be a cool neck.
Definitely could be a good neck.
You have an idea?
>> It can be -- It could be --
>> Shawn Harris: If
I turn it this way,
does it give you
a different idea?
What about that way?
>> It can be their
shoulders probably.
>> Shawn Harris: It could
definitely be a shoulder.
Maybe like a shoulder pad.
Like those are good.
Oh. I haven't heard
from you yet.
>> A pocket.
>> Shawn Harris:
Could be a pocket.
Oh. That's -- I like that.
And what -- And maybe we could
put something in her pocket.
Right? Would that
be interesting?
Okay. Oh. Cool.
That's a good one.
Okay. So we're going to turn
this in to a pocket right here.
But what makes a -- We need some
context here, I think, because,
you know, what makes
a pocket a pocket?
Right? Maybe if she
has a shirt on.
Maybe if she has a shirt
kind of like your shirt.
Oh, you don't have a pocket.
Who has a pocket on their shirt?
You have a pocket on your -- Oh.
Look at it.
McKenzie, right?
Look at McKenzie's
pocket right here.
Let's do a pocket like that.
So I'm going to do a shirt
kind of like McKenzie's.
So if I give her -- If I give
her shirt a neck right there,
and maybe an arm,
and another arm.
And then McKenzie has all
these stripes on her shirt
so I'm going to draw
these stripes.
You see when I just looked
at McKenzie's shirt,
and then I drew it?
That's called research
right there.
That's what that's called.
All right.
Cool. Okay.
So we are almost done.
I'm -- She needs
something more of a head,
and maybe she needs
to hold something.
Do we have any more volunteers
up here that have shapes?
You didn't go yet.
What -- And your name was?
>> Amir.
>> Shawn Harris: Amir
has a shape for us.
Amir, what's it going to be?
This could change
everything, Amir.
No. No. No.
Let him choose.
Let him choose, McKenzie.
We already drew your shirt.
What's it going to be?
Do you want to ask them
what shape we should use?
Hold up your two favorites.
All right.
Amir has his two favorites.
Hold up your left hand, Amir.
Or. Which one did you guys want?
Point to the side.
This one? Okay.
All right.
We're doing this one.
Good job, Amir.
That was very democratic.
What's that?
Thank you.
What could this be?
It could be like a skirt.
It could be a mask.
Oh. That would be interesting.
Oh. Who has -- Who
has our scissors?
Who has scissors on them?
So you know what?
I'm just going to -- I'm
going go ahead and rip it,
if that's okay with you guys.
You guys. She's at
a masquerade ball.
Is that what somebody said?
That's cool.
She's a superhero?
There are so many
interpretations
that we can make.
Right? Look at this.
So now -- Now we
need another eye.
Here's the crazy thing.
We now know something about
her that nobody else knows.
Right? Wow.
I'm going to give her
a little nose in here.
All right.
Okay. Okay.
Let's do one more shape.
I want to put something
in her hand right here.
in her hand.
Let's see what it's going to be.
Okay? Let's see the blue thing.
Let's see the blue thing.
All right.
Another point of interest.
Amir had another one.
What could this be in her hand?
Okay. Hold on.
Let's take hands.
You have an idea.
>> A ball.
>> Shawn Harris:
It could be a ball?
What kind of ball?
It could definitely be a torch.
That would be a really
good tie in to the book
if we put a torch in her hand.
Should we put a -- Let's
put a torch in her hand.
I was going to make it a
ball, but let's do a torch.
A jawbreaker.
That would be the right
size for her mouth.
Right? All right, you guys,
we're going to make
this a torch right here.
We're going to make
this a torch.
That's going to be a torch.
And this is the crazy thing.
Yeah. That can be the stick.
That's great.
I love it.
Okay. Who's got a
piece of yellow?
Yeah. Who's got a yellow piece?
That will work.
That's great.
Give me that heart
too, would you?
Give me that orange heart
on the ground there.
All right.
You guys, while I -- You guys,
while I finish this torch,
can you guys do a slow clap?
Very slow.
And then I'll be done
by the time we get fast.
Okay. All right.
All right.
I'm going to be done by the time
we're -- You're fast clapping.
[ Clapping ]
All right.
There it is.
Okay. Okay.
One last thing that
I want to do.
With my volunteers that were
up here, Amir and McKenzie
and Dikaya and Landon,
Evelyn, would you come up here,
Evelyn, for one last thing?
Would you guys face
the audience?
And stand in a line for me.
Amir, you're going to
be last right here.
Landon, you're going to
be first right there.
Yeah. Right there.
Okay. Now what I want to do
is have you guys tell a story
about this picture that
we all just made together.
Okay? So we're going
to start here.
We're going to start,
"Once upon a time."
>> Once upon a time there
was a statue that was --
that had a mask on with
a torch hanging on it.
>> Shawn Harris: And then.
>> And then.
>> Shawn Harris: You
can look at the picture.
You can look at the
picture for inspiration.
Right here.
All right.
We'll come back to you.
You have an idea of where
to go with the story?
There was a.
>> And then a fish kissed
her, and then the --
>> Shawn Harris:
A fish kissed her?
>> And then the lips
got stuck on her face.
>> Shawn Harris: The fish
lips got stuck on her face?
>> And finally she
finally got a shirt,
and they had stripes on her.
And she -- And her name was.
>> Shawn Harris: Her name was?
>> Lady Liberty.
>> Shawn Harris: Lady
Liberty, everybody.
Thank you to my storytellers.
That was a very inventive story.
What's that?
You can bow.
All of my helpers can bow.
Everybody bow.
On three. One.
Two. Three.
Bow. Thank you guys very much.
Thank you for reading
this book with me.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.